well a criminal investigation has been
opened into Florida Republican Governor
Ron desantis's stunt wherein he paid to
fly 50 migrants from Texas to the
Massachusetts island of Martha's
Vineyard and wow how quickly this has
all developed think back to the
beginning when we first found out that
Ron DeSantis remember Rhonda Santos
governor of Florida
paid millions of dollars in taxpayer
money to fly migrants from Texas to
Martha's Vineyard we thought well it's a
very stupid and Brazen and tasteless
political stunt but that's as far as it
goes at least potentially we then
learned oh you know the migrants were
lied to they were promised things they
were promised that they were being taken
to Boston for expedited something or
other and help getting jobs and whatever
else the case may be that's not true you
know that's sort of like fraudulent
human trafficking maybe there's
something criminal there
and yesterday on the show I had three or
four different commentaries from lawyers
saying yeah this actually does seem like
it's a crime these were folks that were
trafficked illegally by Ron DeSantis and
those deputized by Rhonda santis for
this stunt so that where we left it
yesterday was
what next is there an investigation what
happens next and now indeed there is a
criminal investigation that has been
opened the Miami Herald reporting Texas
Sheriff will investigate Florida flying
Venezuelan migrants to Martha's Vineyard
we have uh video in fact of Bexar County
Sheriff Javier Salazar who explained
what his investigation is going to be
and remember
DeSantis is in Florida but he decided to
get involved with Texas and that's why
the sheriff is from Texas the location
The Source where these migrants came
from we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected uh
activities involving the 48 migrants
from Venezuela that as we understand it
at this point the facts of the case at
this point are that on Wednesday
September 14th uh here in Bexar County
in the city of San Antonio uh our
understanding is that a Venezuelan
migrant was paid of what we would call a
bird dog fee to recruit approximately 50
migrants from the area around a migrant
Resource Center on San Pedro here in San
Antonio you know they talk about
Democrats as the criminals
this is this is just straight up
criminality if it's as alleged uh as we
understand it 48 migrants were uh lured
I will use the word Lord uh under false
pretenses uh on into into staying at a
hotel for a couple of days uh they were
taken by airplane at a certain point
they were shuttled to an airplane uh
where they were flown to Florida and
then eventually flown to Martha's
Vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have that
they were promised work they were
promised the solution to several other
problems they were taken to Martha's
Vineyard from what for what we can
gather uh for nothing for a little more
than a photo op video up
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded in Martha's Vineyard
um what infuriates me the most about
this case is that here we have 48 people
that are already on on Hard Times uh
right they are here legally in our
country at that point they have every
right to be where they are now remember
that that's this is an important detail
the right has been just using the
blanket term illegal immigrants these
are folks as as I understand it and as
it seems like the sheriff understands it
as well and we'll see if he even
explains this who were in the process of
having asylums Asylum claims reviewed
meaning that at this particular point in
time these were not individuals subject
to deportation for illegal immigration
this is an important detail and I
believe that they were preyed upon
somebody came from out of state preyed
upon these people
um lured them with Promises of a better
life which is what they were absolutely
looking for and with the knowledge that
they were going to cling to whatever
hope they could they could be offered
for a better life
um to just be uh exploited and uh
Hoodwinked into making this trip to
Florida and then onward to Martha's
Vineyard for what I believe to be
nothing more than political posturing uh
to make a point well look we all know
that during a political campaign things
can get nasty things can get out of hand
yeah so the point here is criminal
investigation is starting and we're
going to follow it very closely now this
may not be the only criminal
investigation into Ron desantis's stunt
and I say uh investigate criminally in
all jurisdictions where this stunt
um Extended its tentacles Business
Insider reporting a Massachusetts state
lawmaker representing Martha's Vineyard
is Seeking a federal trafficking probe
human trafficking probe after DeSantis
relocated migrants to the island this
article again from Business Insider says
state representative Dylan Fernandez a
Democrat representing Martha's Vineyard
called on the justice department to
launch a probe after DeSantis Charter
two planes for more than six hundred
thousand dollars in taxpayer dollars to
transport fifty migrants from Texas to
the island last Wednesday multiple
criminal investigations being requested
and that is exactly what needs to happen
now the truth again I I hate to have to
be
so apparently cynical
but much like I've said if you're
waiting for the trump in an orange
jumpsuit behind bars moment
um you're gonna be waiting a very long
time
I don't think there is any chance that
DeSantis goes to prison for what he did
particularly when he's the governor and
while the buck stops with him the actual
Acts were carried out and and
logistically organized by people under
DeSantis I I get it guys the buck stops
with him and and that's ultimately where
it where it should stop
if we're waiting around for DeSantis to
end up in prison I think we're we're
sort of putting the target a bit too
high however
is it possible that this stunt and all
of the negative publicity that's coming
with it I mean there's positive
publicity as well from the right
although some on the right aren't
pleased but will the negative publicity
that's coming for it uh from it maybe
hurt DeSantis in his imminent
re-election campaign in Florida whereas
we talked about on the bonus show
yesterday DeSantis is currently winning
by about an average of four or five
against Charlie Crist maybe I think
that's that's the optimistic scenario
not that DeSantis ends up in prison uh
by the way if you did what was done
except it was with young girls to lure
them into prostitution you damn well
could end up in prison but this is
different this is the Republican
governor of Florida but be that as it is
be that as it may uh whichever is your
preference
um I think the the best case scenario
here is this hurts the Santa's
re-election campaign and he's as of
right now looking like he's going to
sail to that re-election at least
there's a criminal investigation we'll
leave it there for today one of our
sponsors today is blue chew a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost and they're giving my audience
an entire month supply for free so if
you think you could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the medic
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping